بالعوده للاجتماعات التي ستقدى في لندن
ينضم لنا الان وزير العدل الاوكراني
سيد ماليوسكا اهلا وسهلا بك سيد الوزير
فيما يتعلق باجتماع وزراء العدل الذي
ينعقد الان في بريطانيا
واعتراضا طبعا على الموقف والحرب في
اوكرانيا
والمذكره التي صدرت تعزيزا لها المذكره
التي صدرت بحق الرئيس الروسي فلاديمير
بوتين من المحكمه الجنائيه الدوليه ما
الذي يتوقع ان ينجم عن هذا الاجتماع
بغرض الرئيسي لهذا الاجتماع هو ضمانه
تنسيق الملائم بين الدول الاعضاء في
المحكمه الجنائيه الدوليه لكي يتمكنوا من
التنسيق من نشاطاتهم
وجمع الادله
والوصول الى البيانات الضروريه وتمويل
نشاطات واعمال
المده العام للمحكمه الجنائيه لان هذا
العمل يعتبر تمويلا من الدول الاعضاء
الغرض الاساسي بالتالي هو التنسيق بين
الدول
ولان الادله المتعلقه بجرائم الحرب التي
ارتكبتها القوات الروسيه وبوتين شخصيا
يمكن ان توجد فيه مناطق مختلفه وليس فقط
في اوكرانيا بل في مناطق ذات ولايه قضائيه
مختلفه سيد دنس المسؤوليه التي تتولونها
انتم الان في الاروقه اروقه هذه
الاجتماعات على ماذا تعتمد ما الذي
ترجونه وما الذي تحاولون اقناع كل
المجتمعين به في خلال هذه المرحله هل الكل
معكم على ذات الصفحه الكل يؤيد مطالبكم
ويؤيد الذهاب ابعد في هذا الملف
الامور امور
الغرض من وجودي هنا هو اولا ان نظهر
التزامنا بتقديم المساعده للمحكمه
الجنائيه الدوليه في نشاطاتها القائمه في
اوكرانيا لذلك نقدم لهم السبيل لكي يصلوا
الى الادله في اوكرانيا ولذلك يمكن
للموظفين الذين يعملون في المحكمه ان
يقوموا بوظيفتهم ونقدم دعمنا ايضا للمحكمه
الجنائيه الدوليه من خلال هذا المؤتمر
ولكن ايضا
نود ان نقدم
منهجا اعرض واوسع فيما يتعلق بمسؤوليه
الاتحاد الروسي الخاص بالجرائم التي
ارتكبت في اوكرانيا ولذلك موقفنا هو انه
ليس فقط بوتين من يجب ان يزج به بالسجن
ولكن الاتحاد الروسي يجب ان يدفع
التعويضات لكي
يقوموا بتعويض الناس بسبب الهجمات التي
قامت بها روسيا لان البنيه التحتيه
الاوكرانيه قد تدمرت والكثير من المباني
السكنيه تدمرت والناس خسروا بيوتهم
والكثير من العائلات
فقدت افرادا فيها اطفال مات اباؤهم
والكثيرون تشردوا لذلك نؤمن ان اطارا
واسعا للتعويض يمكن ان يكون ملائما في هذا
الصدد وايضا القيام بعمل تحقيق جنائي
لبوتين هو جزء من الصوره الكبرى لاننا
نصره ان
انه يجب ان يكون هناك مصادره
لاموال وروسيا واصولها خارجه ارضها
ومع المسؤوله الجنائيه على اعلى الصعد في
الاتحاد الروسي فان هذا يظهر بان الهدف في
تحقيق العداله سوف يتم التوصل اليه في
نهايه المطاف ولكن طبعا الموقف الروسي
والذي جاء على لسان نائب رئيس مجلس الام
معارضا وهذا متوقع ولكن في جزئيه
الخطوره على القانون الدولي هو يقول ان
ستكون هناك اثار واذكر ما قاله ان اصلا
روسيا لا تشارك في هذه المحكمه
وان اسس ومبادئ القانون قد انهارتنا احد
لن يذهب بعد الان الى هيئه الدوليه وسائل
التفاوض الجميع فيما بينهم ما تعليقك
بدون هذه البيانات ليست مرتبطه بالواقع
وهذه البيانات والتصريحات
هي تزور المعلومات لان اي مجرم يميل الى
القول بانه سوف يكون ناجحا في الهروب من
نظام العداله وهو لا يهمه الامر وما الى
ذلك ولكن هذا ليس صحيحا فبوتين وحلفاؤه
سوف يتم اعتقالهم
في اي بلد تابعه للمحكمه الجنائيه الدوليه
وهذا امر مؤلم لهم وهذا الامر مهم لهم رغم
ما يقولون وهذا يظهر ان هناك رساله ملائمه
بان بوتين ليس سوى مجرم حرب الان وهذا امر
طبيعي فهم يحاولون الان ان يرسلوا رسائل
مختلفه الى جمهورهم الداخلي ويقولون هذا
لا باس به فنحن لسنا طرفا في المحكمه
الجنائيه الدوليه ولا يهمنا الامر فقط
ليظهروا بان لديهم خطه ما لاداره الوضع
الحالي وتخفيفي النتائج والتدايات ولكن
بصراحه ليس لديهم خطه نهائيا
والولايه القضائيه للمحكمه الجنائيه
الدوليه هي
تتعامل مع هذه الجرائم المرتكبه في
اوكرانيا وهذا امر سيدنا سر به كل فقد دول
المتحضره
هناك اشكاليه عن النتائج التي يمكن ان
يخرج بها اجتماع وزراء العدل الان وتوابعه
تداعياته ايضا اذا كان الجانب الروسي لا
يقر بالمحكمه اصلا ليس جزءا من اتفاق روما
ويرفض كل هذه القضيه برمتها ما الهدف ما
الذي تتوقعونه من هذا الاجتماع مستقبلا
اذا كانت الاموال ستقر او لا تقر بالنسبه
لكم ما الذي يعني ذلك
ان مذكره توقيف قد تم اصدارها من المحكمه
الجنائيه الدوليه ولا تشمل كل الجرائم
التي ارتكبها الاتحاد الروسي وبوتين نفسه
هناك ايضا جرائم اخرى كثيره لم يتم
التحقيق بها الى الان على سبيل المثال نحن
نؤمن بان جريمه الاباده تم ارتكابها ونحن
نعلم علم اليقين ايضا وهذا امر يعرفه اي
محام
بارع بان جريمه العدوان والاعتداء قد
ارتكبت هذه جريمه خطيره تؤدي الى عقاب
شديد كما ينبغي وهذا لضمان بان كل الجرائم
هذه يتم التحقيق فيها بشكل مناسب وان يتم
معاقبه بوتين بشان كل الجرائم وليس فقط ما
ورد في مذكره التوقيف للمحكمه الجنائيه
الدوليه لذلك هناك الحاجه للمزيد من العمل
والتحقيقات وهذا سوف يتم ونحن واثقون من
ذلك ولكن بالاضافه الى ذلك
نحن ننتظر ونطلب ضمانات من الدول الشريكه
لنا بانهم سوف يقوموا بتطبيق مذكره
التوقيف هذه اذا ما قرر بوتين ان يتوجه
الى اي بلد من بلدانهم وهذا امر مهم بحد
ذاته فهذا يضيق الخناق على سبيل بوتين في
السفر والعمل في العالم اذا فهذا اعتراف
رسمي بانه يجب
ان يقدم الى لاهاي ويحضر الى لاهاي
وهذه رساله مناسبه لكل من يحاولون ان
يتعاونوا معه بانهم هنا يتعاملون مع مجرم
حرب ويؤيدونه وزير العدل الاوكراني ديني
السامه شكرا لك